i'm not a fan of uh resorts uh
where you're spread out i i like to go
to a hotel where i go straight up in an
elevator you know
so here i am staying in this spot uh
that they put us up
uh at a resort it was like half a mile
from
the main desk and you know they they
wanted us even though the shotgun start
was like 11 in the morning
they wanted us to um be picked up at
like seven
go there and have breakfast and whatever
i'm like oh my god that's her this is
when i was in espn i was a single man i
was
out late whatever and i'm like i don't
want to wake up that early
fine i wake up that early woke up that
early and
um standing in front of my uh
spot getting ready to be picked up to be
brought to the
main desk to go all the way out there no
nobody's coming they told me to be out
there at a certain time and someone's
going to come get
still nothing so i call the main desk
now i'm just taking a little breath here
you know but i'm i'm a little heated you
know how it can get
you didn't want to be up that early so i
hop i i busted out my flip phone
and i'm waiting for you know i call the
front desk and i'm like is there anybody
there
who can tell me when this lift is coming
to take me to you so i can get
to this golf course on time and the guy
the person who answers the phone he says
there's a bunch of people here from the
tournament waiting
ready to go and i'm like exactly i need
to be with them can you put somebody
from the tournament on the phone
and the member of the hotel's like is
there someone here from such and such
tournament
and you heard one person go yeah i'm
with that tournament well
you know rich eisen wants to speak to
you and
get on the phone and they're like yeah
hello and i'm like are you with this
tournament yeah i'm with the tournament
i'm like well where
where is the you know i'm trying to be
calm because you know you never know
i'm trying to be you know polite because
that's my default and i'm like but where
is the ride
i think it should be there any minute
rich and i'm like well who is this
so i know and he goes this is brooks
robinson
i'm like oh mr robin said i wanted
somebody who's managing the tournament
not like playing in it
one of the nicest guys ever this is
brooks robbins
great story that's how i welcome jim
palmer to the program how are you jim
i'm good yeah i like he was a nice guy
when he was playing third and i
threw those rockets down you know he was
the mvp in
the 70 world series right so uh you know
the the
one of the great all-star games was the
71 all-star game where
he was played in two hours and eight
minutes and there were like eight home
runs all by hall of famers reggie get
the i was actually warming up by the
blue started the
game for the american league who would
go on to win the uh
cha young and the mvp in his rookie year
but
reggie hit one so far there was complete
silence i mean because everybody's
watching to see how far the ball went
and it went way
up on the roof and you know hit the
light tower and everything a little bit
like the natural except
you know gary levinson wasn't producing
all that kind of stuff jim we had reggie
on the show uh just a couple of weeks
ago
and um he i asked him about that home
run
he said it was born out of salbando
telling him before he went to that
all-star game
don't embarrass us and he thought yeah i
know
as a matter of fact he didn't he most
certainly did not
but i was gonna you know what's funny is
that you know we had played the uh the
reds in the world series here before and
you know we ended up winning uh what
game four four games so one and
you know and brooks brooks made all i
mean
you just don't i mean as good as he was
with 16 straight gold gloves
you don't get the opportunities in one
world series to make all the plays that
he made
i mean you know and i mean it kind of
started in game one when
leigh may had uh singled in a run i
threw him a hanging curveball he had a
two-run home run and i threw a change up
so i'd gone through my
pretty much my whole repertoire and then
that's the ball that brooks catches
going over the bag and from the coaching
box throws the one hopper to boot kyle
to throw out lee may
so now i figure okay johnny bench comes
up i pitched
what was four and five and i figured you
know what i pitched him away in the
world series i'll try to go up and in
and he hits this
rocket in the hole and brooks of course
dies to his left
bench just goes it's just not this is
not fair
and i just figured you know i'll see
what johnny convention can do on the
fastball
you know up and in well i found out but
brooks was there to save me
yeah you know when you talk about you
know he was a
fabulous player but what i mean
personally everywhere i've ever gone
over the years
nobody that i've ever met said anything
bad about chris
you know one of those perfect guys to
have as a teammate and
no i mean i'd say i'm 75 books he's
probably 84 i think somewhere there in
that range
he's a great role model i mean if you
wanted to kind of mirror who you're
going to try to be like when
you know you get to the big leagues at
19 when i did and brooks he's 27
he was like that you're removed from
being the
most valuable player in the american
league it's somebody like brooks
jim palmer here on the rich eisen show
uh jim
how would it have gone if there was a
front office executive
with the baltimore orioles who uh armed
with
uh numbers like spin rate and exit
velocity
would have walked into earl weaver's
office and told him this is who's
starting today and this is how long your
picture is going to go
against that other team because these
are the numbers third time through the
order how would
earl weaver have handled something like
that well you know it's funny i mean
earl
you know earl was the kind of head of
the curve with the weaver cards you know
he had the stats
yes you know he didn't know exactly when
or you know how current they were
you know he relieved me once with
tiffany martinez uh
you know up in new york and i had a four
to one lead he was late in my career
uh you know dave winfield uh hit a um
uh you know an infield hit and then you
know i think the score was
four to one or something like that so
tippy comes out he's well rested
you know i'm happy about that you know
they there's two outs in the ninth
inning and you know i've been nice to
had a complete game but
you know it's kind of i just was looking
for wins i'd already had enough complete
games and
earl comes out he goes you know he's two
for 20 you know
that was only two for 23 and i said well
actually you know
he was over 21 and his last two hits one
was a
arrested tippy martinez on a curveball
down the weight over the shortstop's
head
to beat us and then the other one was an
upper deck home run with 12th inning
uh when he had pitched five straight
days and his curveball was meandering up
the home plate and we were goes what do
you mean
i said well see numbers don't tell you
the whole story
and even today we all know that's not
the case you know
we have a you know sigmeidol does uh you
know he's a nasa guy that
work with mike elias who's now the base
you know the president of baseball
operations in baltimore
you know he was kind of telling us how
important runs are and
you know i mean you know if you do
enough analytical things well you can
save
you know 35 37 runs a game whatever
year a year and whatever so we're
walking down the stadium about two and a
half weeks ago and
i said you know i kind of i went back to
2007
and i looked at run scored per
game in the major leagues and i said
they're down
so if you know we're now at the three
outcomes which is strikeouts
you know uh walks and home runs if home
runs are that important
how come we're hitting more home runs
but we're scoring more
more run more less rounds are scored in
a ball game
and he looked at me and he smiled he
said i'm gonna have to get back to you
on that one
and he's really a nice man you know but
the point is i don't know you know
analytics are
what they are you know the you you know
you give a young pitcher who has a bad
wind up that can't repeat it
you know we want you to pitch in this
quadrant you know you know if you you
know if you do this if you do that if
the edgertronic the
rhapsodial camera tells you you stay
behind your
slider and you know you do this and
whatever but if you can't repeat your
wind up
what what good is the information you
know
i mean if uh you know spin rate we knew
about spin rate
i mean i i used to always ask elrod
henrik who caught my no hitter and said
all right how am i getting these guys
out because they don't see the ball
they think they can hit that high
fastball and i'd have guys like jim
spencer the late jim spencer
he was old for 32. i kept him from
hitting 300 two straight years
and i'd see him i was pitching on
wednesday in texas i'd see him on monday
when we were shagging and then we had
infield back in those days
enfield now feel for the game he goes
you know i'm not going to swing at that
high fastball on monday
tuesday he says you know i'm laying off
that idea of course on wednesday
first high fastball he'd pop it up or
fly out or whatever
so in the 12th inning it's going for my
20th win and
jim mckeon blows up play mike hargrove
was out by about a half a step
and calls him safe and instead of being
winning two to one it's two to two and
i'm trying to you know win my 20th it's
late august and jim spencer comes up and
you know he was a little fast ball
hitter i'm you know you're in a tie ball
game
2-2 in the 12th inning and i throw him a
fastball away and he gets a little soft
line drive a lot tonight look over i
said do you want the ball
i said you know he was from baltimore he
used to play in our basketball team i
said
you could have been doing that for the
last two years so we
knew about where to pitch guys we knew
that you know as elrad henry said they
don't see the ball you have
you know you have a high fastball that
has apparently great spin rate
you know what i thought my first world
series game was sandy colfax's last game
and andy i'm on deck in dodger stadium
and sandy throws
that andy etc in three fastballs and he
thought about swinging
at all three of them and he never could
get the bat going
so as i'm walking up to home plate i i
said uh
i said the radio balls he said what i
said you know you could hear him but you
couldn't see him
so i walk up the home plate and he
throws and i was pretty good hitter he
throws his
fastball and i it starts in the lobby
and it ends up on the second floor
i said no i'm going to um i'm going to
really have to get going
well he throws me the same pitch except
it's not his fastball but
you know now there's a term cuddling
where if you throw
the pitch out of the same you know
release point
they don't know the difference well rose
girl catches it on the ground
and that's how high learned how why
sandy cofax was sandy kofax
because he had a fastball and a
curveball pretty much the two pitches he
had
you could never tell the difference one
started in the lobby ended up on the
second and third floor once started the
lobby ended up in the lower basement
so you know baseball hasn't really
changed it's just
you know i think they they want to you
know quantify it and all that but
i mean you know i know pitchers are good
and they're throwing
with more velocity and you can talk all
day long about whether they're using
substances or not
but at the end of the day you know ted
williams tapped his
bat on the plate in 1969 said you know
boys
get a good pitch to hit preferably a
fastball you need to have a six degree
upswing
so he talked about launch angle back in
1969 and of course he was ted white
yes jim palmer here on the rich eisen
show um i could talk to you all day but
uh before i let you go jim i do want to
give you the floor on shohei ohtani and
we're seeing a unicorn uh
every fifth day and certainly every
other day um
i'll give you the floor and what we're
seeing from him right now well it's just
amazing
you know i mean let's read an article
this morning about you know babe ruth
tell me what pitched and played the
outfield in what 218 games
and he said you know you can't do both
well connie can't
but how big has he got i mean he's it's
like he's you know we know you know i
mean if
you broadcast for the orioles in the
american league east you know you're
used to seeing stan
and you know and and and judge and all
that i mean guys that are super human
they look like they should
you know be on the uh you know in the in
the movies and
you know in the you know some of the you
know the superhero movies and all that
so
um but ohtani just you know i saw him go
a couple years ago when we could
actually go on the field and talk to
players and all that
yeah you know i mean and then you saw
him run and he said gee let's fall a
long way now he gets the ball
real long way to all fields you know
pitching wise
my associate was the manager i said you
got to get him in the middle of pitching
rubber he's going to hurt his arm which
he did
so he did the tommy john you know it's
it's
i mean it it's it's it's it's kind of
what al michaels used to always talk
about he said
you know when you could be reading a
book and when when uh now hitting
for the oakland a's reggie jackson you
you stop reading
when otani pitches or comes to the plate
you
pay attention yep so i don't know if you
can say it any better than that i mean
i'm sure
people could say it much more eloquently
bob costas comes to mind when we talk
about that but yeah he's a special
player
and uh you know if you're if you're an
angel fan you know or you you got to
see tom siever strike out the last 10
batters you know in april
what april 22nd in 1970 right
you know just to think that you were
there or you get to see ohtani do some
of the things he does that's what makes
baseball the game it is jim i appreciate
your time i think uh
i think uh who who's that what's in
what's name your dog that's letting you
know uh
i named it teddy grossman's a
world-famous gun man he's 90 years old
my i have a stepson with autism and
spencer said so
let's name him teddy grossman so
we have a human teddy grossman who lives
in santa monica and then we have teddy
grossman who's barking in the background
a little wired
i'm about an hour south of uh from uh
from atlanta
got him five years ago the day that
jordan's speak that the two balls in the
water
we were an hour away from the little
spring dachshund farm where we got to
the animal we drove 1200 miles from palm
beach to get them uh
when the speed dumped a couple of balls
in the water on 12 which
i had done too so i know it's you know
of course he's not supposed to be a jim
palmer
well let's see him uh throw one up and
into johnny bench one day jim and see
how it works
rich take care thanks for the call jim
look for my call again i'd love to
love to keep this conversation going
thank you appreciate it welcome that's
jim palmer check him out colin orioles
games and
also on twitter fun stuff from jim
palmer right there here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here